bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce magazine été dédié au jardin
hors du commun exceptionnel insolite ou
historique je vais vous emmener aux
quatre coins de Saint-Quentin en
evveline pour découvrir des coins de
verdure inattendu et pour commencer nous
sommes ici à Versailles au Potager du
Roi qui abrite aujourd'hui l'école
nationale supérieur de paysage il faut
imaginer qu'ici lorsque le roi soleil
décide d'implanter son palais à la
hauteur de sa démesure le jardin mais
aussi le potager doivent égaler la
grandeur de l'architecture alors pour
parler de ces plantations royales nous
avons rendez-vous avec le responsable de
ces lieux Antoine Jacobson bonjour merci
de nous recevoir bonjour alors il faut
imaginer qu'ici avant qu'on décide
d'implanter des jardins des potagers
royaux c'était des marécages c'est ça ça
s'appelait c'était un lieu dit de
Versailles qui s'appelait temp pur ah
ouais ça dit bien ce que c'était en
disant qu'on a toujours des remontées
d'eau alors c'est un véritable tour de
force de réussir à créer un potager
Royal ici c'est ça mais c'est un peu
tout le phénomène si je peux l'appeler
comme ça versaill c'est un c'est un
exploit d'avoir créé sur cet espace ce
château ce parc y compris ce potager sur
ce site c'est donc Jean-Baptiste
laquintini qui va on va dire dessiner ce
jardin qui va le mettre en place qui va
le cultiver cela dit il va le faire en
collaboration avec par exemple Jules
Ardoin Mansard alors euh monsieur de la
quentinie qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ici
comment il fallait l'imaginer ce ce
jardin à l'époque alors il faudrait déjà
commencer par l'imaginer comme un un
marais qu'on va euh on va dire drainer
sur laquelle on va rapporter des terres
et ensuite on va construire on va dire
un grand carré central et une toute une
série de jardins autour et
particulièrement quelque chose qui est
donc euh h très spécial c'est ce système
de promenade sur terrasse inséré dans un
un réseau de mur pour essentiellement
cultiver les arbres fruitiers mais aussi
pour on va dire faire un jardin clos car
il faut protéger ce qu'on est cultive et
puis grosse responsabilité pour ce
Jean-Baptiste de La quentinie il doit
fournir les tables royales c'est pas
rien il doit fournir les tables Royal il
il doit surtout fournir donc la famille
du roi mais grosse responsabilité oui
mais pas que ici Jean-Baptiste
laquentinie aussi directeur de tous les
jardins fruitiers et potagers du roi
donc ici Fontainebleau Saint-Germain et
d'autres encore alors il a réussi un
tour de force un peu particulier il
produisait à contresaison des fruits et
légumes quelle technique en fait il
utilisait est-ce qu'on peut expliquer un
petit peu comment on faisait pour
produire à contresaison alors on va on
va parler que de ça parce que sinon il y
en a d'autres hein si on parlait que de
contresaison la chose la moins bien
connue aujourd'hui et la plus connue au
17e siècle c'était ce qu'on appelle la
couche chaude la couche chaude c'est un
on va dire dire un un tas un tas long
une sorte de bande longue de fumier
généralement de cheval tassé
arrosé qui se mettra en fermentation
donc qui produira de la chaleur et sur
laquelle on va mettre il mettait mais
encore on le fait encore aujourd'hui
parfois une couche de terreau dans
laquelle on va planter dans laquelle on
peut semer ou dans laquelle on va
planter et donc même en janvier on
pourra voir avec cette chaleur en
dessous on pourra produire des plants ça
c'est ce pourquoi il est toujours connu
aujourd'hui mais fin 17e début 18e
siècle la ctinie étant mort en 1688 même
bien après sa mort ce pourquoi il était
le plus
connu quelque chose un peu technique
hein c'est pour la création du système
de plantation à racine nues alors
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est-à-dire que
Louis XIV lance des gros gros travaux
comment faire ces gros travaux à moindre
coût et la quentinie par une observation
on va dire scientifique des arbres pas
seulement des arbres fruitiers va dé
terminé qu'en réalité on peut planter
l'hiver début d'hiver surtout à la
sortie de l'hiver avec des arbres qui
n'ont pas de mote et à laquelle on va
couper la plupart de leur racine et ça
va permettre le transport de grande
distance de grands sujets ça va
permettre le transport de petits sujets
aussi mais sans leur mote d'assez loin
pour faire on va dire pour pour pouvoir
planter sur des grandes espaces est-ce
que c'est des techniques qui sont encore
utilisées aujourd'hui
absolument cette cette question de la
plantation de la racine nue vous allez
le voir pour tous les rosiers ou tous
les arbres fruit
fin de l'hiver c'est ce qu'on va vous
proposer plutôt que des arbres en mot
Louis X lui-même aimait beaucoup se
promener dans le potager Louis 14 je
pense était fier de son jardin je pense
que Louis XIV avait un âme de jardinier
et quand il venait se promener sur les
terrasses ça ne l'embêta pas non plus de
descendre dans le jardin pour regarder
les arbres de près éventuellement même
les tailler allons-y
allons-y
nous parlions du roi qui aima taillé à
cette époque on taille pas beaucoup et à
l'époque on faisait pascoup ce qu'on
appelle ta env on enlev pas beaucoup de
feuilles pendant la végétation par
contre là je vais vous montrer quelque
chose que Louis X connaissait que peu de
nos concitoyens connaissent encore sur
un arbre quand il y ATI quand il y a un
bouquet de fleurs sur les poiriers en
particulier entre 5 et 9 fleurs toutes
les fleurs peuvent être pollinisées et
on se retrouve parfois avec des bquets
des bouquets où il y a plusieurs fruits
oui et là vous voyez celui-ci vient de
tomber dans ma main de ce bouquet là il
y a quatre il y en a bien trop pour
l'arbre et on va en enlever un ça
s'appelle l'éclaircissage ça c'est
quelque chose que le roi Louis XIV
connaissait je vais vous montrer encore
un exemple ici hop celui-ci est en trop
alors ce jardin c'était une véritable
fierté pour Louis XIV il y a amené des
ambassadeurs de Siam de Venise alors
l'ambassadeur du roi de Siam et le doge
de Venise lui-même hm hm une des
spécialités de Venise vous savez c'était
les asperges et Louis XIV était très
fier des asperges que produisait la
canentini je vais vous montrer c'est pas
au même endroit encore mais on cultive
certaines choses qui ressemblent
beaucoup à ce qu'il y avait ici au 17e
siècle allons-y allons voir
ça alors on arrive au niveau des
asperges c'est ça voilà donc quand vous
êtes à la campagne dans les Landes ou en
Sologne et que vous voyez des des des
terres où il y a des butes comme ça vous
êtes dans un aspergeré ici nous avons
donc Emma et à côté nous avons une
variété de la fin du 18e siècle qui
s'appelle l'asperge active d'Argenteuil
et on voit bien que Emma qui est issue
de de croisement avec l'argenteuil Emma
est plus vigoureuse et on va dire moins
sensible aux maladies donc une variété
ancienne beaucoup plus sensible dans ce
cas aux maladies que la variété moderne
et en plus emma est plus productive et
au goût pour avoir fait l'essai sur
moi-même et avec quelques uns des J
jardier nous pour le moment entre nous
on trouve pas de différence entre les
deux ah he donc toutes les variétés
anciennes sont pas nécessairement
meilleures que les variétés
modernes et donc c'est ici que vous
vendez les fruits et légumes tous nos
produits frais sont vendus chez nous y
compris la plupart de nos produits
transformés là vous avez ce qui reste
d'un grand marché de ce matin des
cerises des fraises du misizuna un
crucifère un brcic une sorte de moutarde
d'origine japonaise toute une série de
laitu des radis des navés des blettes
des oignons blancs de la sariette et je
peux continuer merci beaucoup pour tous
ces renseignements je vous propose
maintenant de découvrir un jardin au
parfum d'ailleurs à Guy en cour ang
desfut cultive des fruits et légumes
exotiques
regardez des cerises des pommes mais
aussi des bananes des kwii et des nchis
à Guill encour le jardin exotique de
angdfo a des allures de jungle miniature
ça c'est en chinois c'est un chou
chinois
aussi deux fois par an la jardinière
organise les portes ouvertes au grand
bonheur des amateurs de nature et quand
vous faites cuire après les feu devient
ver et le jus devient violet
voilà ah oui
joui c'est la première fois que je viens
visiter ce jardin je j'ai toujours voulu
ça fait des années que je veux venir et
c'est enfin cette année j'ai réussi à me
décider et ce que je découvre c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus grand que ce que je
pouvais imaginer pour moi c'est une
cohabitation de d'arbres et de plantes
parce que tout se mélange et tout est
libre on a l'impression que les plantes
se sentent bien ça c'est fantastique
c'est vrai on a l'impression
que ell cohabite très bien il y a pas de
PL de malade elles sont toutes en bonne
santé enfin c'est super quoi néo Laos
ang défaut est arrivé en France pour ses
études elle vivait en appartement et
c'était la naissance de ses enfants
qu'elle a choisi d'avoir un peu de
verdure 800 m car à entretenir alors
qu'elle découvrait le jardinage les
grosses bêtisse que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai j'ai planté les pommes de terre
avec qui qui ont germé et j'ai j'ai mis
les germes à l'extérieur je croisis que
c'est ce sont des germes qui qui vont
qui vont sortir de la de la Terre et qui
vont qui vont qui vont fleurir et quand
mes voisins ont vu ça ils m'ont ils sont
venus voir non c'est pas comme ça il
faut faire il faut les enterrer angfo
est aussi responsable du groupe des
Jardiniers de France sur 50 ans eneline
un groupe qui compte une centaine
d'adhérents et qui organise ateliers
échange de plantes et conféren tout au
long de
l'année dans la rue ou dans leur propre
jardin ils plantent pour donner les
membres des incroyables comestibles
viennent de s'implanter à 50 an en
Eveline reportage avec Julie
rochaarez donc là on a du th de la
ciboulette du romarin donc ici on a des
topinambour que j'ai finalement laissé
dans un sac pour qu'il soit qui conserve
mieux et puis qui prennent pas l'eau en
fait donc et du laurier sauce du
jardin à prendre des légumes et herbes
aromatiques à disposition et gratuit de
quoi étonner les passants car les
jardinières de Mélissa dans le village
d'élancour sont disposés côté rue sous
laaffichette nourriture à partager selon
le concept des incroyables comestibles
avec les incroyables comestibles bah
c'est l'idée qu'on peut partager
simplement ce qu'on a en abondance ben
plutôt que de le laisser mourir de le
jeter moi je trouve que ça nous redonne
un petit peu de pouvoir à nous en tant
qu'individu de se dire ben je peux
planter des choses je peux les manger et
et mieux je peux en proposer aux autres
et le partager des productions locales
qui proviennent de son propre potager ou
des jardins pédagogiques environnants le
phénomène philanthropique né en
Angleterre il a 5 Ré à la crise devenu
mondial il prend doucement racine depuis
un mois à 5eline un projet citoyen
solidaire soutenu par l'association 5 en
transition et suriniter les person les
voisins les personnes qui les écers tout
le de de goûter et et en fait ça ça
ouvre une conversation sur qu'est-ce que
c'estalimentation locale ce n'est pas
pour
remplacerchage local c'est vraiment de
de faire une conversation qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire nous pe manger
localement qu'est-ce qu' pousse ici en
saison cette saison li Montaine a fait
de nombreux semis pour en faire profiter
tout son
entourage fleurs comestibles il y a les
d'ind parce que ça peut éloigner les
insectes
nuisibles différ sort de salad des
cibouettes encore des fleurs comestibles
ça c'est un pommier que j'ai planté avec
une graine parce
que en plus de ces initiatives
ambitieuses de particulier des mun
vlinoise devrait mettre en place
prochainement des bacs en ville pour
créer des potagers partagés estampillés
incroyable comestible à suivre
donc en périphérie de trappe un
passionné de bonzaï collectionne depuis
des années ces petits arbres au point
d'en avoir plus de 50 dans son propre
jardin reportage avec Julie rochade
Soarez voici Monsieur bonzaï en tout cas
c'est comme ça que l'appelle ses amis
attrape cet Indien né à pondichéie est
tombé amoureux des arbres miniatures il
y a 20 ans et ça plus quitté pour moi
c'est tout mon bijou voilà donc c'est
tout pour moi
c'était j'ai pas de différence t tous
comme des enfants pour moi c'est des
enfants voilà donc je regardarde comme
des enfants je travaille dessus tous les
jours pratiquement dans ce petit jardin
il bichonne une cinquantaine de
conifères de feuillu et même d'arbres
frutiers vous avez des pommiers vous
avez des pommiers qui sont en pomme tout
petit pomm que vousvez et oui un bon
zail pommier donc là
plein de pommes donc ça va être Auton on
peut faire un cidre peut-être une
passion qui nécessite une véritable
rigueur dans le respect de la tradition
nipone c'est bonzaï c'est codifié par
les Japonais donc il veut vraiment CIF
sa première branche gauche deuxième
branche droite trème branche derrière
donc haur de taille de AR qui le peau et
cetera c'est tout est calculé le doyen
de ces arbustesin érable japonais plutôt
imposant un arbrissau de 70
ans